if Anka Trump is shutting down her
namesake fashion line in a statement
yesterday she said quote my focus for
the foreseeable future will be the work
I'm doing here in Washington but the
brand has been facing controversy and
financial pressure bianna golodryga is
here with some of the unanswered
questions beyond oh good morning good
morning everyone Ivanka Trump says she
doesn't know when or if she'll ever
return to the business while she claims
that her decision is the only fair
outcome for her team and her partners
some are questioning why she's chosen to
take this action now you can see we have
everything Ivanka Trump's decision to
shut down her 11 year old company came
without warning Tuesday doesn't seem
like her employees were really told of
it more than really within the last few
days and it's also surprising because
she's been pushing ahead in some
respects internationally her brand's
gotten a lot of trade marks in China
Ivanka's fashion line focused on
mid-priced women's clothing shoes and
accessories she had already given up
day-to-day management of the company as
she told Gayle King last year what have
you done with your business I have no
involvement with any of it and I felt
like proximity to my father into the
White House I didn't want to also be
running a business so I put it into
trust
still Nordstrom and other retailers have
dropped or scaled back on Ivanka's
products citing declining sales
prompting the president to tweet my
daughter Ivanka has been treated so
unfairly by Nordstrom White House
adviser Kellyanne Conway also promoted
Ivanka sales sparking ethics complaints
because Ivanka company is private it's
unclear how profits have been impacted
since her father became president online
sales reportedly fell 55 percent in the
12 months ending in June we're sort of
relying on the fact that they've told us
consistently that she's been profitable
she hasn't been hurt by the White House
so we can accept her explanation but it
also seems like there could have been a
lot of other factors that perhaps played
a role behind the scenes Abrams tells us
the company's 18 employees are expected
to be leaving in the next few weeks it's
unclear what sort of severance they'll
receive but we do know according to
Ivanka Trump's financial disclosure
filings that she earned more than five
million dollars from the trust last year
so what's key is what she does next
because she says she doesn't even know
if she's gonna go back to the industry
back to creating her own company or
maybe politics are in her future who
knows
thanks bianna see